centre-ville de Montréal.
On change la vocation de
viennent y habiter.
Olivier Vachon.
- Ah oui!
- Nous sommes chez Cook it.
L'entreprise montréalaise qui se
spécialise dans le prêt-à-manger
et le prêt-à-cuisiner est
en pleine expansion.
et cofondatrice de Cook it
- On s'en va dans un magnifique
quartier, le Vieux-Port.
- En janvier, elle déménagera
son siège social dans de
ne seront pas plus grands,
bien au contraire.
- On passe du 12 000 pieds
carrés, puis on tombe à du 4500
pieds carrés, mais ça va nmemem.
- Avec des employés qui sont
maintenant en télétrlll
la plupart du temps, Cook it
a choisi de réduire la taille
de ses espaces derererererereren
immeuble qui a grandement besoin
d'amour pon n n édifice plus
prestigieux.
- C'est vraiment pour améliorer
l'expérience employé, c'est
quququququququququququququququq,
d'accueillant, que les gens ont.
- grgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrg.
LAURENT BENARROUS, associé,
titititier immobilier agréé
- Les gens échangent deux pieds
carrés dans un immeubledans un e
supérieure. Avant, on consommait
x,x,x,x,x,x,x,x,x,x,x,x,x,x,x,x.
♪ ♪ ♪
du télétravail a causé
un tremblement de terre dans
l'univers des tours à bureau.
Dans le quartier des affaires,
leur taux d'inoccupation a
pour passer de 9 à 18 %.quququq-
ville de Montréal, vous avez
l'équie e e e e trois fois
le un Place Ville-Marie
qui s'est libéré.
dededededededededededededededed,
généralement de 5 ou 10 ans
de nombreuses entreprises
se délestent de l'espace
qu
- Ce qu'on observe, c'est
une réduction en moyenne de
20 à 30 % des surfaces
- Le marché actuel est donc
à l'avantage des locataires.
immeuble, les propriétaires
doivent en donner plus.
CHRISTIAN CHARBONNEAU, vice-
président, CBRE Canada
- C'est une compétition,
pour que un choisisse d'aller
dans un édifice versus l'aut
bien, il y a un propriétaireprêd
carré pour que tu puisses
t'aménager dans mes locaux.
Et je vais te donner peut-être
12, sinon 24 mois de loyer
- s s s s s s s s s s s s s s ss
où qui se font vieillissants
élélélélélélaissés.
RUTH FISCHER, vice-présidente,
DG, CBRE Canadanonononononononoà
vu ça avec quelques immeublesic.
- C'est une nouvelle réalité
pour les propriétaires, alors
qu'ils avaient le gros bout
du bâton avant la pandémie.
Avenue McGill collège,
par une entreprise, était
pratiquement désert lors
de notre passage.
C'est la firme Canderel
qui gère l'immeuble,
Malgré tout, son patron
BRETT MILLER
directeur général, Candere
- Il y en a certains
dit : "Bon, on ferme
complètement nos bureaux,"
simplement pour iiiiiiiiiiiiiiii
disent : "Non, on va louer
dans les meiblblblblblblbles,
les meilleurs espaces," ils vont
réinvestir, "pour en fait,
atti
- Mais Brett Miller convient
que les propriétaires d'édifices
doivent se montrer flexibles,
de plus courte durée.
Ils doivent aussi rendre leur
immeuble le plus attrayant
on a aménagé un salon près
de l'entrée et un cent
de conditionnement physique
est en construction.
- Pour les employés, ils n'ont
pas besoin de prendre un
ils ont ça dans leurs espaces de
travail.
- Bref, il faut maintenantVoVoVl
boutique. C'est pas simplementl,
vous louez une expérience.
Alors ça, c'est le défi pour
les propriétaires aujourd'hui.ot
vers le centre-ville pour allers
à bureau du lundi au vendredi.
La baisse d'achalandage se faitt
spécialement destinés.
GLENN CASTANHEIRA, directeur
général, Montréal centre-ville
- Alors vous pouvez imaginer
le cordonnier, le nettoyeur
ou le comptoir à sandwichs
de la tour à bureau, sont
les premiers à vraiment
souffrir de cette absence
de travailleurs-là.
- Mais globalement,
les commerçants tiennent bon.
- Si on prend la rue Sainte-
Catherine, qui est vraiment la
ville, plusieurs détaillants
nous rapportent avoir des ventes
similaires ou même supérieures
à 2019.
- La vitalité du centre-vill
population locale et elle est
en pleine croissance.
De 2016 à 2021, le nombre
de résidents a grimpé
de 17 % dans l'arr
Ville-Marie, pour at
- Le centre-
croissance démographique
dans t
- Uniqueme
- Jamais les résidents
du cen
à eux seuls combler une perte
d'achalandage, que ce soit
de
À l'inverse, je vous dirais :
est-ce
résidents? Eh bien là, je serai.
- Pour l'instant, les résidents.
Si l'exode des travailleurs
se poursuit, le portrait
pourrait changer